quem nunca deseja mudar de família
depois de um desentendimento
a família do amigo sempre parece mais
perfeita do que nós
embora sejamos muito críticos em relação
aos nossos pais a atenção o afeto eo
amor que recebemos deles são essenciais
para o nosso desenvolvimento saudável
tanto físico quanto psicológico
segundo o conselho nacional de justiça
existem mais de seis mil crianças aptas
à adoção no brasil ou seja crianças que
moram em instituições de acolhimento e
só em pertencer a uma família com as
qualidades e defeitos que todos nós
conhecemos
eu nasci na serra gaúcha
numa casa bem humilde era de madeira e
tinha alguns degraus na porta de entrada
lembro de sentar esses degraus e
observando os meus irmãos mais velhos
subindo numa árvore
essa árvore eu tenho quase certeza no
abacateiro quando eu tinha um pouco mais
de três anos de idade
eu fui removida fui retirado da minha
família biológica não por causa da
situação financeira mas por questões que
envolvam risco tanto pra mim quanto para
os meus irmãos eu demorei um certo tempo
para entender o significado de ser
adotada
e essa é uma das primeiras imagens que
eu tenho eu estava brincando com o mais
novo amigo e vizinho do andar de baixo
gustavo
na adolescência eu soube que nem todos
os meus quatro irmãos tiveram essa
oportunidade
essa chance de recomeçar a sua vida no
ambiente familiar mais equilibrado na
época da minha do são meninas brancas
tinham muito mais chance de serem
adotadas que meninos negros
felizmente em 2015 as questões sociais
não são mais os principais limitantes
das chances de uma criança encontrar um
lar e no cadastro nacional de adoção
existem cinco vezes mais pretendentes à
adoção registrados do que crianças aptas
a
então por que têm crianças crescendo em
abrigos porque a maior parte dos
pretendentes à adoção deseja adotar uma
criança de 0 a 5 anos de idade como
aparecem em verde no gráfico enquanto a
maior parte das crianças aptas à adoção
tem mais de cinco anos de idade
a indiferença e desconhecimento acerca
da realidade brasileira e da situação
das instituições de acolhimento impedem
que as pessoas reflitam a respeito
causando esse descompasso entre o número
de pretendentes à adoção eo número de
crianças aptas à adoção a realidade
expressa neste gráfico foi a
justificativa para o meu trabalho de
conclusão de curso em design visual na
oit
o objetivo do projeto era sensibilizar
os pretendentes à adoção sob os aspectos
positivos da filiação do ativo com foco
na adoção de crianças a partir de dois
anos de idade identificada como adoção
tardia quando decidi abordar esse tema
me deparei com perguntas do tipo o que
um designer entende sobre adoção um
design visual pode trabalhar na
comunicação de informações em prol de
diferentes causas sociais
mas como afirmou o autor francês cara só
uma comunicação mais eficiente
uma campanha publicitária isolada não
são capazes de provocar profundas
mudanças no comportamento humano pois
estas devem vir acompanhadas de outras
políticas mas mesmo assim por menores
que sejam as nossas ações
elas vão contribuir para mudar essa
realidade
e foi com essa mentalidade positiva que
comecei a pesquisar sobre o universo do
pretendente à adoção participando de um
grupo de apoio à adoção
nesses encontros mensais procurei
entender as preocupações angústias e as
motivações de quem deseja ter um filho
por adoção
minha missão nesse universo não me
mostrou comida é deveria ser mas o que
ela deveria possuir para que a
comunicação fosse impactante ea ideia se
espalhasse
minha mensagem tem de ser acessível a
todos de baixos custos de produção
e ser atrativa meu público alvo durante
a etapa de geração de idéias alternativa
que mais se destacou foi a produção de
uma série de vídeos que aguardaria os
principais temas relacionados à adoção
os vídeos seriam uma forma de refletir
os depoimentos dos pais adotivos que
participam dos grupos de apoio à adoção
e que servem de exemplo para aqueles que
estão se preparando
a idéia de serem vídeo era o mais
importante porque poderia ser veiculada
em plataformas como o youtube sem custo
e sendo acessível a qualquer pretendente
à adoção com acesso à internet
o conceito do projeto estava baseado em
três diretrizes
sinceridade respeito ao evitar explorar
as questões dramáticas que envolvem
crianças abrigadas otimismo instrução ao
ressaltar os aspectos positivos da
adoção e sensibilização um incentivo ao
espectador a procurar mais informações
sobre a adoção de crianças maiores da
idéia de fazer uma série o passo inicial
gravar o primeiro vídeo ea pergunta mais
crítica era eu sei filmar no caso não há
como aprender a filmar youtube a mesma
plataforma que serviria para a
divulgação dos vídeos também é ótima
para aprender sobre filmagem gravação de
áudio edição correção de cor e animação
não isso não propaganda explícita do
youtube mas para colocar uma idéia em
prática é preciso fazer um teste
um protótipo nesse caso gravar um vídeo
e aprender com os erros e acertos da
primeira tentativa no fluxo do processo
de inovação social inicia se pela
geração de idéias
em seguida o teste piloto e com base
nesse teste são feitas melhorias no
projeto para sua implementação e
futuramente sua expansão a gravação da
primeira entrevista foi bem difícil mas
as seguintes foram bem mais fáceis e no
final de 2014
dois episódios foram lançados um canal
do santa dia no youtube
nesses vídeos três pais e seis mães por
adoção contam quais eram
suas expectativas como superar um
período de adaptação da criança e dão
conselhos para futuros pais e mães enfim
o projeto foi apresentado e depois da
aprovação dos meus professores eu sentia
aquele alívio
estou formado há alguns meses depois
comecei a me questionar se essa teria
sido a minha contribuição máxima
comecei a relembrar as oportunidades que
eu tive na minha vida
o esforço que meus pais fizeram para que
eu conquistasse todos os meus sonhos e
as festas que ele sempre organizaram com
tanto carinho para celebrar meus
aniversários
então por que não dar continuidade ao
canal do santa dia e continuar gravando
vídeos que sensibilizem futuros pais e
mães bom como profissional recém-formado
a última coisa que eu tinha era sobra no
orçamento para continuar bancando mais
vídeos e depois de passar oito anos na
universidade
pedi para os meus pais continuem
financiando o projeto não estava entre
as minhas alternativas
meus amigos sempre me incentivaram a
continuar dando continuidade ao projeto
principalmente a mariana e atsu disputa
já tinha feito as ilustrações para os
primeiros episódios e me passou a
confiança que faltava para iniciar uma
campanha de financiamento coletivo e
buscar apoio para a produção de mais
episódios
nesses vídeos tratariam os assuntos como
a adoção de crianças com doenças
tratáveis e não tratáveis e adoção por
casais homoafetivos
depois de 50 dias de campanha e através
de mais de 80 foi a dores
nós conseguimos um valor suficiente para
gravar mais quatro episódios
as filmagens começam em breve
durante a minha infância eu me mudei
várias vezes em nove escolas e ao fazer
novas amizades
eu sempre será um pouco pra contar que
era filha adotiva
confesso que gostava de ver a cara de
surpresa dos meus amigos quando estamos
sabendo ainda existe um estereótipo que
filhos adotivos são
emocionalmente frágeis agressivos e
problemáticos
o que pode ser verdade mas vão precisar
de apoio para superar o tempo e foram
negligenciados
mas o que precisa ser ressaltado é a
capacidade de resiliência do ser humano
o passado não determina o futuro e as
crianças que estão institucionalizadas
não só merece mas tem o direito a
pertencer a uma família assim como nós
tivemos e assim como o felipe o vitor
tiveram recentemente
muito obrigado